OK, we're going to have more about this next
topic coming up next week.
So I don't wanna spend a ton of time on it,
but I think given the events of the last seven
days, it bears mention if we've learned anything
over the last seven days.
Yes, we've confirmed that Donald Trump can't
lead.
But we knew that.
But we've also gotten reinforcement that Donald
Trump is not going to go peacefully if he
loses to Joe Biden in November.
Now, I've said before, this is not some ominous
conspiracy theory where Donald Trump will
be able to stay in power indefinitely like
a king.
I continue to believe that if Donald Trump
loses in November, he will leave.
He will leave eventually.
But he's going to do it under protest.
And it's not going to be what we traditionally
think of as a peaceful transition of power.
Remember, he won in 2016 and has been arguing
that it was rigged against him.
OK.
He won and has spent three years saying the
results can't be trusted.
Yale forensic psychiatrist Dr. Bandy Lee is
now warning that the shows of strength at
really the shows of spalls strength, false
displays of strength from Donald Trump over
the last week foreshadow his likely behavior
if he loses the 2020 election.
So when we say false displays of strength,
we mean the Bible photo op.
The tweets and statements about sending in
the military.
His obvious lie that he didn't go to the bunker
for protection.
On Friday, he went to inspect the bunker.
Give me a break, dude.
The idea is that all of these completely transparent
shows of supposed strength are Trump laying
the framework for continuing to build illegitimate
power so that later in five months he will
question the results of the election.
Here's another example blaming the protests
on an TIFA in order to try to disqualify the
overwhelmingly peaceful protesters.
And they're completely respectable and and
real motives for protesting.
So it's interesting to see a psychiatrist
put a name to it.
But the reaction from anybody who's been paying
attention is, well, yeah, Trump has been laying
the groundwork to complain about the upcoming
election results for a long time.
Democrats can only win if they cheat.
That's another one that Trump has been using
off and on for the last year.
Trump has slowly been ratcheting up the authoritarianism,
culminating so far Monday with his threat
to send in the military against the demands
of governors.
Even these little authoritarian slides tighten
his grip a tiny bit.
His priority has always been personal power,
and we have to be prepared for him to challenge
the results in November.
And this is not about martial law.
This is not about suspending elections and
declaring himself king.
I believe he will go, but we have to ensure
that our institutions are actually prepared
to remove him when it happens.
And it may not even, you know, even remove
suggests someone is going to show up by force
and remove Trump.
It's more that our institutions just have
to make it abundantly clear that if his term
is ending, his term is ending.
And if he's not reelected, someone else is
coming in and that's it.
And it I still don't believe that there's
going to be any removal by force.
And I don't want to be a broken record.
But he won and questioned the results.
He won and questioned the results in November
of 2016.
Just imagine what will happen if he loses.
Let me know what you expect in November on
Twitter, where you can find me at Deas Pacman.
You can also get the daily audio podcast of.
The show for free on your favorite podcasting
app, whether it's eye tunes, Spotify, Pandora,
Google Play podcasts, that you're really whatever
you want.
Get the podcast.
Let me know your thoughts about Trump in November
on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a packed show in store for you today.